how old were you when you did Smallville
everything I'm gonna say I'm always off
a little bit my mom would be like Ryan
that's not even true uh so let's say I
think I was 16 the first time the first
season 16. I'm sure you were that old
maybe it was 15. I mean also I I looked
like
you looked young you were like me a late
bloomer yes so that's another thing that
was probably throwing you too man I mean
I just remember and I remember thinking
I'm not just saying this but I I think I
told you I don't know if you even
remember but I was I remember it's just
saying you're really good you're gonna
be you're gonna you're gonna work
I remember telling your mom I was like
this kid's good you're well behaved on
set I don't know if she beat you yes I
don't know what what happened but uh it
was just like you know you watch those
episodes those were the best the two
great episodes that you were in
it was heartbreaking yeah right Ryan
Ryan's oh no I've seen it no yeah yes
yeah yeah because he's had to watch them
because he does talkaville as well with
Welling and um what do you what do you
remember just like going back like what
do you remember I mean 15 you're not
that young no so you probably remember
a bit hey there folks it's Michael
Rosenbaum and boy have I got a huge
announcement for you this has been a
long time comment and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're going to
make it a lot of fun we're planning a q
a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there
um
I remember I mean again like I said my
memory is terrible so
um it's all those droids man with all
your bulk right uh it's dropped you know
living in Hollywood drugs being dropped
in your head
um but uh
what I what I do remember is
Smallville was the first like it changed
my life in the sense of that was I had
been acting when I was younger
um just kind of something my parents
made me do and I enjoyed it don't get me
wrong but it was definitely like not
force but like if I made an obligation
to something mom was like well no you
have to do this right you have to go to
this audition you said you would
um and I took to it I have a bunch of
siblings they didn't like it as much I
kind of loved it and I loved being out
of school I loved yeah acting as much as
I did Sports and Smallville was the
first time that I saw adults
doing it for a living like it clicked in
my head I was like wait I remember you
guys um especially the second season you
guys were going through like talking to
each other about contract negotiations I
remember you remember that a little bit
yeah and I remember thinking like wow
that'd be so cool one day if I could do
that
um but the first one for sure I was like
wait you guys do this for a living like
you don't do anything like you didn't
this is what you do you know and you
guys like yeah so that was the first
time I clicked my head and then that
it's a good thing and a bad thing my mom
probably wishes that never happened
because that was when I made in my head
I was like oh I'm gonna lie to my
parents and tell them I'm applying for
college and not apply to college and
then I'm going to do this for the rest
of my life that's what you thought at
that age right when you're on set that
was somehow it clicked in dude that was
the first for sure Smallville was like
where I was like oh I I want to do this
too well how do I my parents are going
to make me go to college how do I I'll
just lie to them and then you know did
you did you like doing it did you like
acting I loved it you loved it I loved I
loved being on set like that part was
still to this day is my favorite thing
ever you love me you would love the
process I yes of making the art itself
you know as you get older the audition
part is
you still audition a lot yeah here and
there you know I mean it's it's the name
of the game getting back to you know
like right now I'm not currently working
on anything so it's getting back to the
Grind